nouveau centre de vaccination dans les
yvelines il est ouvert depuis le 15 juin
au centre commercial westfield vélizy 2
un espace de 2000 m² mise à disposition
par le centre en collaboration avec les
autorités afin de favoriser
l'accélération de la campagne de
vaccination
je crois que le souhait de la préfecture
de la rl c'est département c'était
véritablement d'aller à la rencontre des
gens ils les formes de l'acsi nation sur
rendez vous c'est je fais une démarche
proactive ici c'est encore plus
dynamique
le centre se déplacer vient à la
rencontre de nos clients ils sont
nombreux et ont peu profité d'une séance
shopping d'un gratin de courses
alimentaires pour faire en 20 minutes
sur une vaccination libre gratuite et au
rendez vous c'est le point le plus
important c'est le vaccin de pfizer qui
a administré dans ce centre sans
rendez-vous il attire les volontaires je
pensais que c'était important de se
faire vacciner donc étant donné qu on
nous mettait à la vaccination sans
rendez vous je trouvais que c'était
plutôt pratique donc je suis venu pour
ma cité c'était vraiment enfin ça rend
la chose vraiment beaucoup plus facile
c'est simple parce que c'est pas aussi à
essayer sans rendez-vous les 12 17 ans
peuvent se faire vacciner depuis le 15
juin mais dans ces centres ils sont
assez peu nombreux ces derniers jours on
a constaté qu'un peu près 10% des gens
que nous accueillons étaient des mineurs
de 12 à 18 ans donc c'est plutôt un bon
démarrage vraiment ici on lance un appel
à tout
tous ces jeunes qui vont partir en
vacances qui vont sortir un peu faire la
fête pour se protéger protéger leurs
proches en venant rapidement sonné vous
gratuitement sur la chine et avec
l'autorisation de leurs parents bien
évidemment le centre de vaccination de
west fils vélizy 2 est ouvert du mardi
au samedi de 10 heures à 18 heures et ce
jusqu'au 28 août